it's nice to have somebody who's
professional thank you well no I just
have that like Charisma that you know
like some people I have the Charisma
thing
not to toot my own horn but it's like I
I'm I'm confident I have a good talking
voice yeah you do
talk talk I bet you you have some good
stories too yeah
Amanda so you were a
you you were not a play-by-play mate you
were a Playboy model yes I'm a cyber
girl cyber girl of the week Playboys
Amanda Hagen for December 7th 2009 and
there's only 53 a year for one for each
week of the year
so I guess that's considered a playmate
runner-up or just a Playboy model and
how did this come about how did you
you're from where uh well I'm from
Newbury Park California
um near like Agora Hills it's the 805 I
don't know if anyone knows kind of the
West San Fernando Valley yeah so I grew
up there and then um I had my daughter
at 18 and then I started working out
heavily at the gym to get my body back
and I was tanning and I was looking
pretty good so I started modeling for
tfcd shoots which is on like Model
Mayhem you're meeting people trading
time for Content you know and everyone
was like you need to get a boob job you
need to get a boob job
um but it took me a while to get to get
that but um so my daughter was about two
and I went online to the Playboy casting
call like I had mailed my photos into
them no response because I think because
I didn't have a boob job it's like a
prerequisite so I go to the casting call
and I'm walking across the lawn and I
see Hugh Hefner and I'm texting my
friend Alicia I worked at Starbucks at
the time my girlfriend Alicia from
Starbucks she's like get in there girl
you know go talk to him
so I run up to and I'm like hi HEV can I
take a picture with you and he's like oh
sure and he gives me a big hug and then
he's like hey
um are you local and I'm like yes he's
like would you like to come to the pool
party on Sunday and I'm like well sure I
would love to and so he had Jenny his
like right hand like secretary [__]
lady
and he's like get her info so I go to
the fun in the sun and then I'm texting
Lisa she's like push the limit sit in
the girlfriend's chairs and I'm like oh
my God so I like sat in the girlfriend's
chairs trying to get his attention they
asked me to move and so I went for a
couple weeks and I was just super like
on his jock like smile leaving looking
cute and then I get a phone call from
Jenny and she's like Amanda you're on
the do not admit list you threw a
lollipop in the Shannon twins hair
because I was there in 2009 it was
Crystal Harris was the main girlfriend
and then it was the Shannon Twins and
that was it I mean there was a couple
side girls which I'll get into in a
little bit but um so she's like you're
on the do not admit list I was
devastated so I called this guy Rick who
like tailors Michael Jackson's pants or
something that I met there and I told
him what happened and he's like you know
half reads his mail right him a
handwritten letter apology he might let
you back in so I write this letter like
dear Hugh Hefner you know I don't know
why what happened but I'm terribly sorry
for any misunderstanding and I'd love to
come back to the mansion and I bake on
my photo did you throw a lollipop in
someone's hair I did not I was because I
was trying to sit in the girlfriend's
chairs they were sweating me you know
the hierarchy the competition they could
tell I was getting for half and I think
half liked me so they were trying to get
rid of me so then
um Hef gets my letter and I'm in the
puppy dog store in the mall with
Victoria my two-year-old shout out to
baby b baby bunny mommy loves you she
knows I'm doing this she's almost 17.
anyways um so it's your daughter yeah
Victoria so uh I'm in the puppy store in
the mall with Victoria and I get a phone
call and it goes to voicemail and it's
Hugh Hefner and it's like hey it's Heff
you're back on the list please wear your
uh purple thong this weekend because I
had a big booty at the time I don't have
my booty anymore but I had a big booty
and he was like super into the booty so
I'm going back there and then uh
Midsummer's Night Dream party comes
along I get an invite because because
I'm on the Fun in the Sun Sunday
barbecue list and so I'm at the party
and then Crystal walks up to me and
picks me under the crowd and she's like
do you want to come sit with us and I'm
like over the moon like this is my dream
come true you know like it's it's a
party and I'm sitting with heffa I want
to have some arm I've looked at Playboy
magazines since I was like 13 and seen
all these girls and I'm like one of the
girls on his arm for the night I was
over the moon in a fantasy land like all
my dreams came to I feel like Alice in
Wonderland like he's like you know like
the queen of hearts in his own little
universe and you know I fell down the
road dreams of anything else for your
life
um I always grew up like wanting to be
like a straight porn star I saw Jenna
Jameson I saw these girls at the peach
blonde hair and the fake boobs and
that's just all I wanted to be when I
grew up was a stripper a porn star a
dancer like ever since I was like eight
that's all I wanted to do
hmm so you're you're what age at this at
this point
um I was 20 21 maybe 22 in 2009 so it's
mid-summer's night dream and the girl
and I had been working as a stripper
trying to buy my daughter some nice
things you know dancing for my baby or
whatever whatever which is weird because
all the girls at the Mansion are total
like strippers but they're pretending to
be College coeds because that's the
Playbook image you're not a you know I
don't know but it's kind of taboo one
time when I was upstairs hooking up with
half Melissa Melissa Taylor asked me
she's like oh girl I dance at the candy
cat what club do you dance at but she
was trying to catch me slipping to tell
half like oh this one's a stripper don't
let her come upstairs with us anymore
like there's a lot of Mind Games and the
girls didn't really like me like Crystal
Harris was the worst like she just
didn't like me like our personality is
just and I super tried but she was just
really [__] and hard to get along with
and I think she felt very threatened by
me when I got my boob job she told me
like the only reason you got your boobs
done is for half and I'm like no most
girls get their boobs done because I
want to improve myself you know like I
want to have fake boobs I don't want to
be an A cup like in the idiot Bitty
Titty Committee you know
so I was like I got my boobs done
partially for myself and partially
because I was hanging out at the
[__] Playboy Mansion like if
any time is the time to get your boobs
done but anyways so being a stripper I
hooked up with men for money maybe in
their 50s for 300 bucks 500 bucks 50 you
know 50 60 so 80 wasn't that big of a
jump but they're like you know tonight
do you want to come upstairs with us and
I'm like this ain't my first rodeo like
I'm good they're like well some girls
they get up there they freak out they
cry they can't handle it
um so we go upstairs and they're like
some girls get in the corner some girls
cry first thing we do is we all get in
matching silk pajamas you can pick out
any color you want he has a closet full
of silk pajamas I think he used to make
the girls take a bath but we just had to
get into the pajamas I picked per
um blue silk and it was like like a you
know the silk pajamas he was like button
up pajamas then we all get on the bed
then he turns on Madonna Material Girl
starts playing that's like his sex iPod
of choice or whatever but that wasn't
iPod back then it was black Berry days
but then three projectors of porn 70s
porn start rolling there's he has this
monster size uh Playboy or I mean
Johnson Johnson baby oil like for show
behind his shelf and then um there's the
Shelf uh there's like a pull out
Tupperware full of sex toys a lot of
Hitachi ones which I super like a lot of
stuff I was excited because I'm bisexual
I'm like these girls are fun I'm gonna
be hooking up with some Playmates but no
I um I had no breast implants like I got
half with like a cups which I think is
pretty cool like he just liked the booty
he liked the face he liked the
personality I think he just really liked
me and I think the other girls like saw
that coming so they were always very you
know like he gave me a hundred dollars
once I felt very proud of that like the
granddaddy of all sugar daddies gave me
a hundred dollars for my babysitter
um one night he asked me to spend the
night in room five but I had my
two-year-old so either my mom had to
watch her and my mom did not really like
babysitting my daughter that much or my
friend Matt I had um my friend Matt from
fourth grade would babysit her for 50
bucks but what is spending the night in
room five mean I'm just getting closer
to being a girlfriend like getting a
room spending the night spending more
days there but I had my daughter so it's
like I could only pursue like Sundays I
was trying to get on the list I asked
Jenny I was like can I get on the list
for Thursday and Friday night which is
like Casablanca Night movie night or I
think how many girls would be in his
rotation
um there was only four it was Crystal
Harris his girlfriend Melissa Taylor his
best friend this girl Anna Berglund
who's living in the Playboy House and me
for six months there was only four of us
but I was a stripper I had to dance for
my baby I had my daughter and he knew
about my daughter I don't know why in
retrospect I didn't just ask him like
Hey can I bring her to the pool can you
get a nanny or something you know it
didn't occur to me but I feel like if I
hadn't had my daughter that I probably
would have moved in but you know I love
my daughter more than life itself she's
like the best thing that ever happened
to me I would trade her for Playboy any
day of the year but you know it just I'm
just you know communicating that was
kind of like a stumbling block to like
pursuing the girlfriend relationship was
like I had to get home to my baby and
but he gave me money for the nanny which
I I should have framed that hundred
dollar bill like this dude gave me money
like are you serious and
um the other girls too like at the end
of summer they were like oh now that
Summer's over once fun and the Sun is
over they downsize the party list and it
moves to the game room so I made the cut
and I was still going upstairs but
they're like now that some Melissa's
like now that Summer's over we don't
want you to come upstairs anymore it's
just us and Heff walks by me and he
winks and then two weeks later I'm back
upstairs hooking up with him but but I
had nipple piercings because I thought
it made my nipples look more attractive
as an A cup like me because I have
really big nipples I'm like maybe it
makes them look smaller but he's like oh
are you like into pain and he has a back
brace one funny thing about him too is
he pretends like he can't understand
stuff because he's all hard of hearing
like what huh but like he totally like
picks up on every little thing like he
was sharp as [__] but he was like like
one time I asked him I was like hey can
I bring my sister and he's like sure put
her on the list next week she's doing an
in-person
tour The Grotto is nice it the what
Holly was saying about the dog pee
carpet stuff is true it is really old
like 70s like red shag carpet that
hasn't been changed in quite a while but
one thing that's important to me is I do
want to speak highly of half like he
made all my dreams come true he's
um
he's like a fantasy maker I mean this
guy like everyone loves him celebrities
like have some poop you know like he's
the [__] you know all these girls want
to say oh I survived the Mansion I think
it's just in Vogue right now to pretend
like you are victimized by the Mansion
like I survived becoming a millionaire
and going on trips and Yachts the rest
of my life I survived being a playmate
and being like one of the chosen 12
girls a year to be one of the most
beautiful women of the world like this
guy is like Marilyn Monroe was like the
sweetheart of the month like I dated
some guy that dated Maryland freaking
Monroe he's buried next to her like I
think it's a lack of gratitude like you
wouldn't even have a platform to be
publishing a book without this
[__] you know and that now they
all want to talk [__] now you mean
Playboy doesn't value what's on the
inside last time I checked they're not
like the magazine about your insides
like Playboy finding quality character
no it's a it's about looks like I don't
go to a strip club and complain about
being objectified so I love Hugh Hefner
I have nothing but amazing things to say
about him it almost makes me want to cry
like it was a fantasy come true I'm you
know at the Halloween party I was
sitting there I was one of the girls on
his arm I've been looking at this since
I was a little girl like this dude made
my dreams come true I think he put the
black first black musician on TV on
Playboy channel playing the saxophone he
fought for American sexual culture like
he's done a lot like politically like
he's the [__] I love Heff and I have
nothing but good things to say about it
he treated his girls well he was
extremely nice like I never saw him say
one Mead thing to anyone like put on red
lipstick or like he's just like half
like everyone was there willingly he
didn't force me to go but he doesn't
like come to my house next week or I'll
kill you like No And if one of his girls
needed a car or needed needed help with
her something oh yeah well Anna one
night you know she she got some plastic
surgery done so she was missing from the
bedroom for a little bit and I was like
hey where have you been the last couple
weeks hooking up you know and she's like
oh you know I got some work done and I'm
like well how much did that cost she's
like well I can't talk about money but I
know if you're a girlfriend you go like
I think it's two thousand dollars
allowance a car but they have all the
rules two thousand dollars a week a
month I think that's what it is I don't
know they get their allowance and
everything you know speaking very highly
of him is very important to me this
interview I don't think anyone was
victimized by being forced to wear red
lipstick or like sorry the carpet was a
little bit old because it's a historic
place that has been there forever but he
makes fantasies come true like I'm sorry
you're a playmate and when you have a
million dollars now I hope your
therapist can help you solve all that
for the girls making that much money
well no I call you just came out with
the book Crystal just came out with a
book called I Survived Hollywood she
Crystal was really mean to me like I'd
be sitting downstairs and she came to me
I have had a few abusive boyfriends and
I shared about that with them and she's
like I see why guys are so abusive to
you like for some reason Crystal like
hated me and Melissa was 31 we were all
like 22. so Melissa Taylor she was um
she's a side Bureau but she's like oh
like oh you know I'm a little bit older
than you guys so you know I'm a little
more mature but Melissa felt Crystal
felt comfortable with Melissa that
Melissa wasn't going to like steal her
girlfriend's box she was 31 she just
wanted to be cyber girl she was too old
but they didn't feel safe with me and I
tried to tell them like I'm a baby mama
I have a baby I have to go home too like
you guys can trust me like I just want
to [__] him I just want to hang out I
don't want to be a moving girlfriend
because I have this baby but even just a
week ago I texted Melissa on Facebook
like or I mean on Instagram and I'm like
hey you know um
I all my pictures of the mention in my
mom's house in the garage and were
estranged we don't talk can you send me
some photos of me and half and she
didn't write me back at all and I was
like do you remember me at least go
upstairs and she's still giving me the
cold shoulder and have stead and he's
been dead for like 10 years and they're
still being [__] to me you know it's
like I just wanted to talk to her but
they're just very the girls were very
cold this girl Chelsea Gremlin came
upstairs one time he had a relationship
with her he was flying her out from like
Iowa she's a cyber girls and sorry to
you ladies if I'm blowing up your spot
but I'm just telling my story sorry you
know but um hope you were honest with
your husband about it or whatever those
type of women get they get very catty
with each other don't they yeah it's
just the cattiness like they were always
trying to get me out of the bedroom like
you don't need to come upstairs anymore
like we got it we just need three girls
but half wanted me up there and I think
if I hadn't had my daughter I probably
would have just started organically like
spending nights there and being a
girlfriend or he would have asked me but
he definitely just liked between